edia world in general now let's do a
refresh of our memory if you will as
regards what has happened Jamel
Khashoggi for the first time on to 28th
of September Friday at 11:50 goes into
the chief counsel of Saudi Arabia in
Istanbul for marriage related reasons
and it is now understood that this visit
of khashoggi was actually in was the
information was given to the team that
planned and executed the murder of the
journalist so that was the beginning of
that planning phase and some consulate
officers officials actually left for
their countries in a haste and this
points in the direction that some
preparation work was indeed done on
October 1st at 16:30 a day before the
operation Monday that is at half past
4:00 in the afternoon
a team of three comes to Istanbul
through a scheduled flight a commercial
flight they go to a hotel first and then
to the consulate so in the meantime
another team of people from the
consulate go on an exploration mission
to the Belgrade forest and through the
city of Yalova on the 2nd of October at
1:45 a.m. a team of 3 people again took
a scheduled flight to Istanbul and went
to their hotel a third team of nine
people including generals took a private
plane landed at the airport and went to
another hotel for the night so overall
the team we're looking at is a total of
15 people and this team of people from
950 to 11 a.m. they come in different
groups to the consulate and meet there
the first thing they do is to remove the
hard disk in the camera system of the
consulate and in the meantime Jamal
khashoggi was telephoned at 11:50 to
confirm his appointment on that day the
send on the same day at early hours
Khashoggi comes from London to Istanbul
and enters on foot into the consular
building at 1308 the fiance was with him
at that point in time and after that
point in time no information was
obtained from him no news of him came
out at 17 15 that day in the evening
hours the fiance mr. Kershaw his fiancee
[Music]
resorts to the official authorities of
our country telling the authorities that
mr. Khashoggi was being held at the
consular building against his will
and that something bad might have
happened to him upon which the relevant
units of the Directorate General of the
Turkish National Police in Istanbul
start the investigation they have a look
at the security cameras examined the
footage and it becomes certain at that
point in time that mr. Khashoggi indeed
did not leave the consular building none
of